what's happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we have a trailer for a
movie I am very much looking forward to
it is called talk to me it is from the
studio a24 but more importantly it is
from Danny and Michael philippu who you
might know better as raka raka we used
to react to so many of their videos I am
very very happy for these guys their
short films were hilarious they show
they know how to do violence and horror
and for them to be doing a movie being
distributed by a24 who just won like all
the Oscars that is nuts massive
congratulations to them because that is
inspiring very very inspiring guys
please go ahead leave a like and let's
see what this trailer is all about
because they are living the the dream
right now that is amazing
[Music]
have you seen the group chat and doing
it again tonight
huh
no please that's my mom's Remembrance
Day
I just want to forget about it huh
[Laughter]
I'll do it
can't go for more than 90 seconds am I
clear what happens after 90 seconds
[Applause]
don't want to stay
[Music]
what is this like flatliners or
something like the candle to open the
door
blow it out to close it
put your hand on it okay
now say
talk to me
[Applause]
whoa
what did the hand feel like
it felt amazing
I could see and feel everything on the
other side
huh oh wow my mom she was trying to
reach out are you sure
I'm here
still been saying stuff damn I got
nipple chills
what if we open the door but we didn't
shut it
that's the question
I'm not gonna stop
[Music]
I like you
oh man Kudos Kudos Sun boys that's
awesome this feels like you have Blum
House and a24 made a movie together sure
yeah got that Vibe because normally when
I think of like an a24 horror movie I
imagine something that leans a lot more
into almost abstract kind of horror you
know
this is very much like Punchy horror
which is cool because yeah I sort of
liken this journey that's going on with
how Jordan peel did get out or someone
you know from doing a lot more of these
like comedy sketches that had those
touches of action and Horror in them
they do their first feature film where I
remember uh the first time I ever went
to WonderCon I got to meet them and I
did ask like what kind of movies they're
really into and they said that the kind
of movies are more into are actually
like heavy dramas so it doesn't surprise
me that to see the trailer for this film
which looks like a blast this looks like
an awesome demonic supernatural horror
film leaning into a lot more of that
type of psychological trauma and that
being the motivator what segues us into
what I imagine is going to be like a
Bonkers very gory horror film of knowing
what their work on YouTube was I'm
excited for it I think this looks really
cool and the the fact that they get to
show off their visual Panache yeah no
absolutely it's it's very exciting and I
mean like you said at the top they're
living the dream and this to me feels
like you know if this was a blumhouse
joint I feel like the trailer would be
throwing more of the exploitable
elements at you and what I like about
this is that this has that a24 thing
where it's like oh it's the dread and
it's the psychological aspect of it but
this is one of those trailers where you
can I mean I'm making an inference but
you can also kind of tell that this will
probably go as Bonkers as you think it
will go and bring some of that Evil Dead
style like gleeful knife twisty grit
along with all the bone chilling and the
you know more character oriented horror
so like I like that they're keeping that
stuff kind of at Bay or at least it
would seem because you just get the
sense or I get the sense from this
trailer that yeah something is waiting
to pop off and it is like a familiar I
mean even just that the hand invokes the
monkey's paw be careful what you wish
for
um and yeah it's got like a nice
familiar setup but it also looks like
something that will kind of Branch into
its own unique end and character
probably character oriented character
driven kind of Anguish and and Mania and
all sorts of other things you see so
much especially Sam Raimi and other
things in their style but I'm really
excited to see like 824 picking this up
suggests that yeah like this is also a
film as much as it will be like a fun
house ride and that really excites me
because you know like the rackaracka
stuff on YouTube is wild and bombastic
and chaotic but now they get to show how
they would sustain a tone over an hour
and a half or so and you know that takes
chops it's a big jump it's like you can
be really good at short form and still
struggle in long form but I've heard
great things about this from the few
times it's screened so far I could not
be more excess this just shot up to one
of my most anticipated this year well
you could feel like The Inspirations you
could just sort of Imagine them on set
being like this is our Sam Raimi shot
this is our Gore verbinski shot yeah
this right here is our James wand shot
this is our Jordan peel shot you can see
so much of The Inspirations and when you
look at what their channel was uh when
especially doing the sketches that was
already what they were doing was taking
inspiration and applying it and and
often doing it in a satirical way do it
in a spoof way here to take it in a way
that really takes it a much more serious
Direction I think it's really cool
because a lot of especially the lighting
choices do remind me of like the gore
verbinsky horror films or the James Juan
horror films yet there's a lot of these
like punches and the way they decide to
use a lot of their tracking and moving
shots that remind me a little bit more
of like Sam Raimi I think this is gonna
be I don't know to me I'm already in
inspired even though I haven't even seen
it I don't even like this movie but I I
think it's really cool that you know
when you when you got his a24 horror
film that the critics that they're
quoting here are the ones from the
hardcore horror Community you know I
don't really weirdly enough I don't
really think of them when I think of an
a24 horror movie yeah but they're
they're citing them for for all the
quotations and so I I think this movie
will be that movie that is really fun
but also surprisingly more nuanced and
I'm excited for people to see that side
of them especially knowing what they're
bigger kind of inspirational factors are
I feel like they'll also be littered
with a bunch of Easter eggs and yeah I
like the whole touch of the you know um
of the how you were like it's like a
monkey spot it's like a combination like
a monkey spawn a Ouija board yeah
anything that gets you into the you know
what's it called in Insidious I
constantly figure out what's further
yeah
yeah yeah into the spirit realm and did
they shoot this in Australia it's sure
feel feels like it and that's that's
another thing too that's kind of nice is
it does feel a bit like an Aussie teen
drama or something like that that then
you know crashes into some kind of
horror thing just even all these friends
hanging out and stuff like that there's
some kind of lived-in feeling you can
feel sort of the air in the room and
yeah I would imagine I don't know like
you know all sorts of circumstances
compile for your first feature but
especially being from there I would
imagine it would be pretty special to
make the movie there and also you've got
so much production value just by being
in Australia even at all funny enough I
see some Lee one now inspiration too
yeah yeah 100 like definitely you know
this is coming past sort of the new
Splat pack you know it's like you have
these the the recent Titans of horror
now inspiring stuff like this and two I
mean I'm curious to see how their
internet shops will come in because one
of the great things about so many of
their YouTube sketches is you constantly
sit there going wow this is nuts and
also like whatever effects there are
look so much better than this medium you
know usually allows for and so now to
see them working with Pro great
equipment and and crew and all that
stuff you know I can't wait to see what
tricks and and things they're able to
pull and and Dazzle us with that way
because they're usually great at making
something look real on a shoestring you
know very true very true all right guys
well what did you think about this
trailer please go ahead leave your
thoughts down below uh subscribe leave a
like tell us your thoughts on what you
think about rackaracka's Journey let's
end this with a
Maria Hammond Maria Maria I have an
unboxing video that's going up and
speaking of demonic horror wow she got
me this Dr Strange collectible which is
absolutely gorgeous and I don't know who
I think these are just generic demons
meant to enhance this imagery of sorcery
but I felt like you know this might not
be the kind of movie that you're gonna
go ahead and watch but I I felt like
shouting out a demonic Doctor Strange
collectible is perfect for this video
considering what goes on here so Maria I
want to thank you for constantly
spoiling us and for constantly showering
us with all kinds of emotional love and
support all the time you are an absolute
Gem and you are near and dear to my
heart especially I love the hell out of
you and I want you to know this is going
to remain on the background for a very
very long time probably permanently much
love my dear thank you
[Music]